[موسيقى]
ياتي هذا الشاب العماني كل يوم الى مكتبه
في منطقه بوشر بالعاصمه العمانيه مسقط
منهمكا لساعات طويله في انجاز مشروعه الذي
يعتبره حلما لطالما اراد تحقيقه خليل
الحسيني شاب عماني يطمح الى توثيق التراث
الغذائي والماكولات العمانيه بطريقه فنيه
وابداعيه
[موسيقى]
مشروع الفنون طهي تحتها عده برامج نحن
جالسين نشتغل عليها اول برنامج اللي هو ان
نحن نعمل
مقاييس معايير للماكولات العمانيه بحيث ان
احنا ننتج كتاب من بعد الكتاب في برامج
كثيره ما نذكرها الحين لان شغالين فيها و-
اا على اساس الفكره الفكره المشروع ما ما
ما احد ياخذها
خليل تجول في الكثير من المدن العمانيه
لتوفيق الاكلات مستفيدا من معلومات
الجمعيات المراه العمانيه في كل ولايه الى
جانبك كبار السن حتى تمكن من توفيق اكثر
من 90 اكله حتى الان
لفينا لمده ثلاث شهور
في عمان وصورنا اغلب الماكولات العمانيه
طبعا الماكولات العمانيه كثيره تتجاوز ال
120 اكله عمانيه نحنا صورنا ال ال
الماكولات النادره
الناس ما تعرف
ين من خلال هذا المشروع الى ترسيخ قيمه
المرور الغذائيه العمانيه
للاستثمار في مجالات الطهي في الحقيقه
احنا عندنا يعني اهداف كثيره في المشروع
الهدف الاساسي ان احنا نكون عندنا محتوى
في الماكولات الفنون الطهي العمانيه نفس
الشيء همم الامام المجتمع
ماكولات قبل ان نحن اا نسوقها للخارط يكون
عندنا اعتزاز همم الناس بثقافه همم الفنون
الطهي العماني بحيث ان احنا همم
ننسخ في همم في العالم ان احنا عندنا اكل
مميز ممكن الناس تجيء قريبا سيقوم خليل
الحسيني باصدار كتاب لتصليط الضوء على ذكر
الموارد الاساسيه في طبخ الماكولات في
السلطنه كزراعه الثوم والبصل وصناعه
الوردي واللوبان عبد الرحمن العصيمي من
مسقط العربيه